ce que vous comprenez ce verdict
forcément dont non parce qu'il est
factuellement déjà erronée selon nous il
condamne karim benzema pour des faits
qui ne se sont pas produites en fait la
conversation alléguée entre karim
benzema et valbuena personne ne la
connaît il n'y a pas de tout à l'heure
vous avez parlé de la bouteille d'eau on
a la vidéo la ja pas la vidéo il n'y a
pas les enregistrements et on essaye de
l'art tissé à partir d'une autre
conversation que karim a eu avec un de
ses amis et moi je trouve que c'est très
dangereux d'essayer d'interpréter des
conversations on sélectionne un mot on
en enlève un autre dans cette
conversation par exemple karim benzema
10 à la fin que mathieu valbuena l'a
remercié c'est un peu étrange de dire
que quelqu'un qui aurait sur lui fait
des pressions lors est remercié donc on
espérait vraiment que au regard de ces
arguments là et du fait que c'est une
histoire quand même qui est très
anciennes sur laquelle on est en train
de parler d'une complicité de tentative
de chanteurs âgés ce couple ce qui lui
est reproché à karim wade va pour les
personnes qui ne connaîtraient pas cette
histoire quitte à passer ce que monsieur
valbuena dit un mois après la
conversation c'est qu'il aurait un
ressenti qui serait que monsieur benzema
au lieu de ce que monsieur benzema 10 et
j'ai essayé d'aider mon camarade en lui
proposant de contacter quelqu'un qui
pouvait faire en sorte que ça s'arrête
ce qui est rien à voir avec du chantage
en l'occurrence et monsieur valbuena un
mois après dans des circonstances un peu
curieuse dit qu'il a ressenti une forme
de pression sauf que en fait on sait pas
exactement ce que les deux se sont dits
et que dans ce cadre là le doute il doit
normalement profiter à monsieur benzema
alors c'est ça n'a pas été le cas c'est
la première minute ça fait cinq ans que
l'on parle de cette affaire de sextape
hees a eu des conséquences j'ai envie de
dire et pour l'un et pour l'autre mais
aujourd'hui la condamnation de monsieur
benzema et l'autre elle est lourde
d'ailleurs le procureur allait il faut
pas le juger comme tout le maximum s'il
est condamné à 10 ans d'emprisonnement
avec sursis 75000 euros d'amendé